you know there is a 20 years old
conversation in the israeli ecosystem
about how to increase
um the participation of the israeli
population in the tech ecosystem
um despite all the news and despite all
the you know what we like to think of
ourselves as a startup nation
it's it's there is a glass ceiling in
the number of employees that actually
walk me in tech
it was a hoovering it was hovering
around 7
percent and still around these numbers
like nine percent of the workforce in
israel
actually works in tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i am joined today by shakhal
khan the founder and ceo of lucid
capital
a software engineer by training has
served an executive product in strategy
positions at tech in israel and silicon
valley
several years ago he founded lucid
capital a tech fund that specializes in
global tax talks as well as late stage
startups
lucid capital is a close partner of the
leading israeli institutional investors
and assists them in accessing and
qualifying direct tech investments both
on the global public markets as well as
the private ones
shakha koin welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you thank you hi mikhail how are
you very good i'm great thank you so
much for being here and you know i'm
excited to dive deep into these in these
20 minutes into a few key understandings
that you've had throughout your career
you've had an incredible career whether
it's out of product marketing with with
cisco back in the valley you've you've
invested in some of the most incredible
companies like agape then
and really companies that are that are
you know
the foundation of the israel ecosystem
and now most recently the co-founder and
ceo of lucid capital and working some
amazing people on some really
great
problems and thinking strategically
about our ecosystem here in israel
globally and where we're headed and i'm
excited to dive deep into a few of those
key insights but before we do all that
take me back just a little bit and and
who are you what makes up shakal cohen
the thinker today yeah so so
um
first i always describe myself as a
teclused geek i'm a geek i am a bachelor
of computer science i was in my back
that past i was software engineer at
intel
um
and some of my best friends are still
you know software engineers and now vpr
and this and stuff um so
so it's you know i grew up with a very
solid tech i would say roots um and then
i i transitioned into the business into
the intersection between business and
tech um
did some strategy roles in in both in
the
giants like hp and cisco
and um and then was vp at the as a vp
product marketing and cyber security
startups and and along the years i've
been you know always in the interchange
between tech and investing this is
my first i would say i've always
discovered myself as um
i do a life this is my first life my
second life has more i would say more
social more um
more social aspect of this of this life
social career um was part of the uh
the founders of um of an ngo named nova
which is mckinsey for ngo and after that
i had the
i call it the um
the right to serve as the um as member
of the kraken bill committee in 2011
that was the committee established
following the huge protest
uh wiped out israel approximately um um
i would say five percent of population
protested in certain certain points so
and and and i think it was always
um
fascinating it was fascinating from the
from
first tech
and also the ability to to um
that the the
the cyanism of tech the ability that
tech fulfill the zionism
ammunition so that's that's where i live
and this is why when people ask me today
uh what do you do i would say i live in
2023.
and i think that's that's in and a
certain point i i took a hobby of me of
tech investing i took it to be a
profession finally spencer food we
established um
a hedge fund specialized in tech stocks
um by the way um name this is capital
but we we have to say that you know this
nothing we say here is going to be
advice or endorsement or any
recommendation of any stock um it's not
any substitution to any um you know
tailored advisement stock advisement you
should get your profession this is all
friendly unofficial efficient and we
don't i mean no different stock exactly
exactly and and and i i think the
ability to to analyze
tech stocks or analyze
growth
um or pre-ipo companies both from the um
you know understanding the financial
understanding where they're going in
terms of strategy this is my background
and also you know and
getting the implication on the israeli
ecosystem this had the i so i had this
unique perspective of being able to see
the strangers and this is what what
brings us to this conversation is this
conversation and so one of the things
one of the things that i that i really
enjoyed reading in preparation for this
is a sort of a thesis you know of three
main three main trends that you're
observing or three main things that need
to happen
or that are happening
as part of this ecosystem that you've
been thinking about over these last over
these last years and so what i would
love to do is i would love to sort of
you know expand on each one of those
separately for a few minutes
and understand a little bit better
because i think that it really is an
interesting strategical thinking behind
what's happening here and what we're
observing the madness of the tech
industry in the scale-up nation yeah i i
you know there is a 20 years old
conversation in the israeli
ecosystem about how to increase
um the participation of the israeli
population in the tech ecosystem
um despite all the news and despite all
the you know what we like to think of
ourselves as a startup nation it's it's
there is a glass ceiling in the number
of employees that actually walk me in
tech
it's was a hoovering it was rivering
around seven percent eight percent and
still around this number it's like nine
percent
of the workforce in israel actually
works in tech and and there there is a
20 years old conversation how can we
make it
because that will you know create a
leapfrog in the gdp of israel that could
get the leapfrog in the in the workforce
education that can you know take israel
to be one of the um you know terms of
gdp maybe increase it to
twofold you know yeah if you think about
that
and and and the the this is like
a very old-fashioned conversation and
always the answer is like let's invest
more in in in mathematics you know
studies let's uh let's have government
funding for r d which is okay which is
right but still
we didn't break the glass ceiling it's
still nine percent for that you know it
doesn't cross the ten percent for the
last 20 years despite the sparks and the
funding and all things happens
and and i think like any technology that
can be any 20 years old technology we
need also that you know is ripped for
disruption you know like the on-prem
versus the cloud
it's time also to i think to
uh debunk some myths
in that conversation and that's what
i i guess we're going to talk today so
tell me a little bit about you know what
you're what you're thinking about
yeah so so
let me ask you i always always when i
meet with people and discuss this this
topic i always ask them you know what's
the greatest
the largest expenditure of a tech of a
software tech company typical software
let's say
palo alto
um weeks fiverr monday
take one of you know the israeli
unicorns what's the what's the biggest
expenditure
it must be their engineers so exactly
people always say engineers
and if you open you know the financial
report and this is my my job i always
was amazed that between
engineering r d is usually between 15 to
25 30
of the expenditures
the
most of the of the of the
money expense on sales and marketing and
support in weeks it could be sixty
percent of the revenue monday is is is
close to seventy five percent of the
revenue
and and and it's not unique by the way
it's also it's not just usually
companies it's every such company
their largest expenditure even slack
slack unity of slack it's 90 of the
revenues are expense on sales and
marketing wow
and that's mind-boggling yeah because
you always think of them as a tech
companies but no they are more like
marketing companies
and and and the reason by the way
the reason
is that the whole assumption that
analyze the sas model is that you know
it's very sticky so once you acquire
customer it will it
it will stay with you for the for the
coming of five years and then you should
invest currently in sense and marketing
because you're quack it's like land grab
play where you basically acquire a
customer and then it stays with you and
and people tell me okay but you need to
deduct the you know the advertisement
the facebook and google i say okay let's
let's deduct that it's like between
10 to
15 percent of the of the marketing
expenses you still get
that the sales marketing and ultimate or
go to market is much larger
in terms of dollars um a budget from
from the uh the over revenue also by the
way in terms of the number of employees
um
in
weeks for instance there yeah you know
um you have 60 60 percent more than 65
percent of employees
that are not r d and and and and i
deduct for that point you know the um
the designer and the ueex guys that
counted within the r d in monday most
you know monday or
take any or walk me most of the
employees more than
60 of the employees are not r d
so
and that's not and again that's typical
i think that's that connects to the
other
myth that surrounds the israeli
ecosystem
israelis cannot we cannot build large
companies right
but always the conversation is like
um i we wish we had 10 more checkpoints
in israel
but actually there are you know actually
there are you know if you look look just
last month exactly jfrog wix fiverr
sentinel one
day yeah they all are like you know
between
4 billion to 10 billion dollar market
cap growing liquid
and you know building composition is
where nobody's going
they're basically growing like big
companies
wix is now having its own building its
old campus building a few kilometers out
of tel aviv
and and fiverr i guess will follow
and and and that that raises the
question that what what happened what
the
with the week's founder of the five of
founders are more zionist or more
capable than the let's say the
the last generation founders
i don't think so the reason that we have
managed israel has managed to to build
in the last five years
and not just unicorn that sells you know
two billion dollars for cisco for stuff
but real companies that employ that
employees
thousands of employees
ipoint and get the funding from the from
their capital markets and keep growing
and keep rising
and the reason i believe it's not like
that the founders are more zionist or
more capable or have less you know
uh you know they have more long-term
thinking i don't believe that you know
because it's it's so
structural change that's happening in
the in the global tech ecosystem and
this is the
the change is the ability to do
go to market more remotely so if you
think of the israeli tech ecosystem 15
years ago now there was many like
on-prem on-prem software hardware and
telecom equipment
those are you know things of amado so
converse or you know even checkpoint was
mainly on-prem
so those are companies that needed to
develop
on the ground go to market people that
would go and this is very hard to do
yeah and this is why you know when you
get into a certain point the companies
prefer to be sold to cisco which has
they go you know they're all the guys
that play golf with
the account manager
and that makes sense because cisco both
pay you know half a billion dollar and
and one year afterwards every six guys
in cisco can reach to the indonesian iit
guide in bank and sell but
the sas revolution
enable doesn't you know enables you to
to do it remotely
you can you know people in inside sale
insert rape acquire customer via the via
facebook and google and basically
that change of the way of doing go to
marketing go to go to market
basically make or
build the rationale for for companies
okay we can we can continue growing
without investing so much without need
to grab
every cisco's account manager without
need to develop this in-depth
relationship with you know the cios of
the companies let alone companies like
jfrog or elasticsearch where their
clients or they they are all monday that
they are growing bottom up they don't go
to the cio and says okay this is what we
can do let's sign you know one billion
dollar or give you a ten percent
discount then it's like the the the
devops guy download jfrog install and it
starts deploy it and then you know after
six months the jfrog you know says guys
just need to go to the ceo tell hey your
employee your employers are using our
solution already they only pay us so
let's make it you know in most
structured ways the whole idea of
product led growth you know that's been
growing over the last few years i think
it's it's and it's so amazing because it
really speaks you know if you're looking
at behavioral economics and rationality
it really speaks to the value creation
exactly it's not about some c-level
executive that
that that alone believes something is
happening you're seeing the value
creating from the ground up and if there
is real value then it's going to be then
it's going to scale up and i think it's
amazing now tell me a little bit about
the low code and no code revolution and
how that is shifting in in the ecosystem
yeah so so just to to nail the last
point what i'm saying
is that
the combination of
the
the revolution the way companies do go
to market the debt of the salesperson in
a sense not really but in a sense
combined with the um the the um the
infrastructure companies need to build
in order to
um to to expand it's mostly
go to market people like you know
campaign managers ux guys um project
managers uh design guys and and customer
success people
and those
are
jobs
that can be created in israel
and so you you don't necessarily need to
have anyone to be like a software
engineer you know going to work as a
cyber expert at checkpoint
it's okay if you take someone that is
more
operational or and teach him the soft
skills of tech
you know more language skills german
skills or german language or english or
find the accent and stuff you know teach
him all the tools that need to that need
to be used in order to be a great
customer success guy or get campaign
manager and all the best practices
and and and have them join not in salary
of 50k niss a month with typical
software engineer
seasoned software engineer gets but 25
kms per month which is still
2.5 times the adversary israel and i
think that's that's could be
the way to break the glass city i'm not
saying there is not the the companies
themselves
do not have problem raising or getting
talented software engineers they have a
problem and they you know they will
struggle and they they all continue
further
forever but this is not
the key problem of the israeli states
the usually government need to not not
and it's just just you know if you add
another 2000 software engineer it won't
raise the bar you want to have 50k
people joining in sales marketing
support
position in two weeks monday sentinel
one uh whatever j froggit stuff so
that's just to nail the point
and and and and
and now getting today to the next point
about local norwood
the other tech revolution that currently
happened happening in quran accelerate
that very much
and it's that the local notebook think
of local no code as as as
platforms like
do it yourself or or wix for coding yep
and and that stands exactly from what
you mentioned the the pain to get
software developer is universal
it's across the whole globe this is why
where there's so much pain
so someone develop a solution so we have
seen microsoft salesforce um servicenow
as well as dedicated as well as
dedicated companies like appian stuff
developed what would they call low code
it's like wix for coding which which
basically enables any i'm like analyst
business analyst that know how to do
pivot table in excel
to design or to write an application a
and a workflow application for i don't
know and embarking a customer in
insurance class in in a in a bank or you
know claim management and insure
insurance company
and and that's that's my problem because
now you can take
the people with
relatively you know
mild analytical skills you don't need
them to have you know to train them and
to basically to to training for one year
or two years to be like software
engineer or cyber export at checkpoint
they can work as as local developers or
builders where they can build software
application without needing to write
even one line of code amazing
and that that connects to the previous
point so now you can take all this
biology or chemistry or sciences or also
business analysts that you know just
economics graduate or or business
administration graduates and and and
teach them local no code don't
put them there but don't you know put
the bar of being you know software
engineer or researcher that you know
solve a huge algorithmical uh or
mathematical problem you know it's okay
if they get they will work maybe for a
professional service company it could be
you know israeli professional service
company like oh it could be like even
like infosys or or um
or cognizant or accenture that they are
really
um looking for local developers but not
just not just local developers for those
companies
for every for instance for every fintech
everything the company could use local
developers to do all the integration
with the legacy system 100
so okay there will be the the the uh the
what let's call it the talented software
developers they do all the ai the data
scientists the guys that do the you know
that sort of the core algorithms of the
business but for all the gluing stuff
all the interfaces
low code is perfect that's perfect and
and
i think i think you know all going over
these three three key ideas which are
obviously all very much interconnected
they're impacting each other but overall
we're not just talking about making the
israelite ecosystem but we're talking
about making israel better and exactly
we're talking about a greater problems
for the world than you know you're
taking israel but then you can
extrapolate this to every other country
in the world because you know obviously
as the world moves forward we're it's
all going to be in tech and there's no
way there's no way around it and and
countries have to either get with the
program or they'll fall further and
further behind and luckily we're we're
living in a city and a state and a
country that is thinking critically
through those programs and i'm really
excited that there are people like you
that are sitting in there actually
thinking critically about this but i
want to spend the last two three minutes
just going back a little bit
and understand you a little bit better
go back to your childhood for me yeah
middle school what really fascinating so
you mentioned you're a geek but what
really fascinates you yeah so i i am a
bit ashamed to say but then i i
basically participate in the support
group and understood that my i would say
my assassination or the what the things
that fascinate me is is common to a lot
of people it's not it shouldn't i
shouldn't be ashamed of that and that's
the uh i'm what is called in ibu
mercofun i really i really love you know
weather storms so i'm stone chaser
you're a storm chaser i think that i i
was fascinated and i'm still fascinated
by
storms
and and this is also you know i'm
getting better so this is like this is
the way and and i you can you know in
the most stormy day in israel you can i
basically take day off and go to the
north and chasing thunderstorm and stuff
and i think that that stayed with me
well i think we're going to be doing
another episode just on that what
inspires you today
i believe that
people that go against the wind yeah and
think of guy warning for instance in
israel that went against you know
against the what
i would say concentration in the
business individually business climate
10 years ago
and to risk he could you know
play the game
and get some more
advertising dollar to his newspaper but
he decided to go against the most
powerful
you know
entities in israel
and and as well as for instance a woman
that complained about sexual harassment
against powerful
people i think
that's always always
inspire me
the ability of people to do something
that against you know their immediate
interest for the sake of others that
inspires me i love it and what are three
words you would use to describe yourself
geek for sure geek
i i think
curiosity i think this is the person
this is driver of i i i
you know i i get energy for from
learning so geek and curiosity yeah i
think weakness and curiosity i think
that's the um
that's how i would describe myself
i really want to thank you for coming
this was amazing and thank you for
sharing uh you know part of your
strategical thinking and i'm sure that
there's so much more that we didn't even
get to uncover yet and and i think it
sounds it sounds incredible and and i'm
excited to continue this conversation
and to explore more and this is what our
country needs in the world needs and and
it's just this was a very exciting time
for me so thank you very much thank you
for watching